along well for a lot of other great
attorneys who are working in the
background who I will mention briefly
before we bring up the ones who knew
George Floyd
all of his life I want to thank lawyers
towing in the vineyards like Devin Jacob
Chris O'Neil Lee Merritt Darryl parks
Jasmine ran bill Pentos and Carol Powell
xyn because Europe may see Tony and
Chris and I but it's a whole team of
lawyers who are working because it's
going to take a united effort in in the
courtroom and outside the courtroom to
get justice for George Floyd I will tell
you all that because of the corona virus
pandemic we have to stay on a strict
schedule and we all help to do this
social distancing but I want to just put
it on the record revenue that it was not
the corona virus pandemic that killed
George Flores I want to make it clear on
the record
Rodney Floyd his cousin Sherita taked
his nephew Brandon Williams please come
to the stage and I would ask attorney
Tony Ramanuja an attorney Chris Stewart
to come and stand with me behind them as
united they tell the world while we
should celebrate the life of George
Floyd
please come up family my name is
felonious Floyd brother Josh Floyd well
we come up together we didn't have much
our mom did what she could we sleep in
the same bed play video games together
you know play catch with the football
and I used to say to myself like man you
can't throw you can't throw at all you
know I mean because the ball never came
to me and years down the line cuz I was
catching with one hand two hands
anyway you through it I started being
able to catch it he said I can throw I
just wanted you to go get the ball
the ball don't need to come to you you
need to go get the ball
but you know my brother we did a lot of
things together from like talking with
my mom dancing with my mom cooking with
our mom brothers and sisters so much we
made banana mayonnaise sandwiches
together you know it was it was a family
thing
you know everyday we know when we come
in the house our mom was gonna have a
huge plate of food separate from each
other and we were sit there and although
with you said who played the woods and
I'm like in like 10 I live in I'm
talking about the plate with six pieces
of chicken his mind and he way bigger
than me
you know man he's huge so ma'am from
from that being in the house with my
brother man it was just like inspiring
to other people because my mom used to
take in other kids and most um was
George's friends and they wanted to stay
with her they loved her you know and my
brother he was okay with it
so then you had three to me they were
grown din because they kicked me out of
the room three men like 16 17 they grown
sleeping in the same bed waking up going
to the same school and they would leave
each other at all they always wanted to
be with each other at all times
I remember nights when the day before
school we didn't have a washing machine
so we were all go in and put our socks
and underwear in a bathroom sink and
just start washing them and watching
them and we didn't have detergent we
would use soap but we were watching
we're gonna be cleaning clean so we were
literally right after there we would
take the socks and hang them over to hot
water heating we take the underwear
hanging over there and we will fight
about it me and his friends and all of
you like No
no no you did it last night because your
clothes piling still be depth and then
stay if you don't put it on a hot water
heater from from that and we've learned
a lot of stuff but it's crazy because we
would like we didn't have a dryer so the
best way to dry your clothes with the
put it in the oven and let it dry faster
like that so it was just man I love my
brother man we had so many memories you
know together
I remember him waking me up telling me
hey man can you iron my clothes and I
look at him but then I look at his side
and I say you right big bro you're right
it was just it was just amazing
everywhere you go and see people how
they cling to him they wanted to be
around him
you know George he was like a general
every day he walks outside it'd be a lot
of people like just like when we came in
wanting to greet him and wanted to have
fun with him
guys that was doing drugs like smokers
and homeless people you couldn't tell
because when you spoke to George
they felt like they was the president
because that's how he made you feel he
was he was powerful man he had a way
with words he could always make you
ready to jump and go all the time
everybody loves George we didn't call
him George
we called him Peary if you if you called
him Perry you knew him direct you know
cuz George was the name everybody called
a big George a big Floyd you know
Georgie Porgie has so many different
names but I'm gonna go here and I'm just
crazy man all these people came to see
my brother and that's amazing to me that
he touched so many people hearts you
know could he been touching our hearts
you know you come to third war where
we're from
people are crying right now that's how
much they love them you know I'm just
staying strong as I can
cuz I need to get it out I need to get
it out everybody want justice we want
justice for George he's gonna get it
he's gonna get it good afternoon
everyone I'm just going to echo some of
the things that felonious talked about
and that is that we come from a long
line of large family members our mothers
were siblings of 13 and if I can kind of
fast forward a little bit
my aunt moved to she lived in Houston
and she would always talk about being
there not having any other siblings
close close to her so my mother decided
to move to the Houston area back early
80 81 and so we we came to Houston and
we were all excited that we could have
somebody close to us because the only
time we really would see each other is
like doing the holidays or when people
would travel to visit my grandmother
long story short I mean we didn't have a
whole lot but we always had each other
and we always were taught that you know
we could always bring other people into
the fold always no one should ever go
home without having a meal or having
food and so that's how has he talked
about my aunt was someone in the
community everybody they called him a
[ __ ] and all the kids loved to come
over there and she ended up having you
know 30 or 40 kids that would come over
there because they always knew that they
could get something to eat if they came
there and not only food but they could
be loved and they could feel a part of
the whole so we were raised to always
welcome people in and to embrace other
people and so you could see as all these
people no matter who you talk to they
will all say the same thing and that
George was somebody who was always
welcoming always made people feel like
that they were special and nobody let
felt left out and he would enter into a
room everybody would feel like they were
special he would embrace them as I think
about the thing that I will miss
about him most is his hugs like he was
this great big giant and when he would
when he would wrap his arms around you
you just feel like you know you were
everything could just go away any
problems you had any concerns your head
would go away so while we're all
breathing I just want to kind of
highlight his children you know
Quincy javion Townsend iike tyson and
Gianna and his three-year-old
granddaughter journey we all need prayer
but if I am honest about it we are more
concerned about his children his
grandchildren so I asked as you pray for
us as we go along this marathon to make
sure that justice is served on Georgia's
we have or Perry as we call him ask that
you pray for us and especially for their
children thank you how y'all doing
I am writing it for youngest brother of
Joyce flow and my brother PJ was talking
about childhood memories and how we grew
up and I would like to start wait
leftovers growing up all that great
stuff I was dried and washed our clothes
that was just ingenuity innovation and I
mean hey we work we have but didn't have
much but we had a house full of love and
I mean I appreciate the love of everyone
in here in this state of Minneapolis
y'all adopted my brother and showed him
so much love and we feel that love in
your city and thankfully everybody
impressed around the world it's a
beautiful thing this great love we
receive him and Joy's father is
receiving because he would love it
I wish was here in a presence in the
flesh to see the cloud this great unity
he would bring unity like bringing us
but she had fun maybe my brother before
it iago cooking wise he would make me
honest for him and other brothers three
genuine my brother Mitchell grew up in
our house so they would say liberal
you'd like the best grilled cheese can
you please don't leave
that's what if I tell y'all 67 yoki I
did that number of times I realized that
I got older y'all just using me big
brother I mean great guy great gentleman
great man and as a child without no
father figure he was a big brother but I
didn't see it in this stuff they were
throwing around he was doing the best he
can and the mistakes eBay and I watching
them following him corrected myself as a
grown man that the teenagers growing up
and you know learning from him how to be
a man everything here in stories and
todos he was doing here but he was
teaching us how to be a man cuz he was
in this world already before us he gave
us a lot of great lessons and I mean one
thing about a man keep the definition
Florida responsibility he was standing
up for his family in France and he's
great at that and I want you guys to
know that he was standing up clean any
injustice everyone okay yeah please I'm
Brandon Williams George's nephew no I
called Pierre
you know we happen to share the same
middle name for some reason my mama
wanted to name all of us after some
other siblings and coincidentally
I ended up with George I'm a lot you
know getting them but my grandmother the
reason I'd have a father figure present
in my life so I grew up in the same
house with him and you know my uncle's
were more of a father figure in my life
but Perry being the alpha male you know
I gravitated to him it's coming up I
play sports he did you know they kind of
connected us brothers were a close on
and try not to be sad this is lot harder
than I thought it would be
I just remember I just remember just all
of the memories man so more than
anything I just want to say thank you to
him on just for being there she's been a
really genuine person just being loving
and caring at somebody I can count on no
matter what oh we didn't have much but
coming up my grandmother tried our best
and wherever she select he picked it up
for me he made sure I had sneakers and
clothes and a lot of stuff like that I
appreciate that
on on my ended with on a funny story
about all he was the biggest lebron
james fan and i remember i don't know if
you guys are familiar with the NBA but
when the cavaliers they came back on the
Golden State Warriors and the finals and
I remember the very first phone call and
I told him oh man you too happy you
sounded like you want to championship we
laughed about it there you know he said
man you know how I feel about LeBron I
didn't win the championship so and every
time we were talk and I asked him - hey
how you doing man
you're good and he and he said I feel
like I want a championship and that kind
of stuff it was just this inside thing
we had so I know him being a strong
person he was and seeing everybody come
together and just rally around them and
they stand out of the love and support
our family and and we thankful and
grateful and I know more than anything
with everybody grieving and hurting here
we want us to feel like we won the
championship so I end on that note
thank you
yeah please give another round of
applause please show them love thank you
all so much for bearing your hearts if
we learnt one thing the floor boys like
to eat and also they had a conversation
with Tyler Perry and it was pretty
profound because they said we are the
big extended black family that you
portray will packet and others on your
movie screens because we all need one
another and you can tell this family
always need it George and so it's
awfully difficult for them the plea for
justice is simply this dr. Martin Luther
King said he who passively accepts evil
is as much involved in it as he who
helps to perpetrate it he who accepts
evil without protesting against it is
really like cooperating with it you know
T on that video what we saw was torture
Reverend Johnson what we saw in that
video was inhumane
more in the third what we saw in that
video was evil and saw America we
proclaim as we memorialize George Floyd
do not cooperate with evil protest
against evil John two young people in
the streets protesting against the evil
the inhumane the torture that they
witnessed on that video
we cannot cooperate with evil
we cannot cooperate with injustice
we cannot cooperate with torture because
George Florida's they are better than
that we all deserve better than that
his family deserve better than that his
children deserve better than that
Stevo George wanted from life is what
any of us want as Thomas Jefferson said
in the Declaration of Independence the
an amiable race
endowed by our Creator Therese to life
liberty in the pursuit to be happy on
this earth that's all George was asking
for like any and all of us but he was
denied those rights and we will seek
justice in his name we will all United
as a people who are God's children seek
justice in his name but beyond the
specific justice in his case Chris the
prosecution of the for individuals who
deprived George of his life we seek a
brighter more transformative justice
revenue and more gests system of
policing Kevin a more jest treatment of
people of color Chris a more jazz
criminal justice system in essence what
we are endeavoring to do
Brandon is what my personal hero
Thurgood Marshall said make the
constitutional make the Constitution
real for all Americans
you see justice Marshall said the basis
of the Constitution is simply this that
a black baby born to a black mother the
most an educated black mother
most inarticulate black mother the most
improvers black mother has the same
exact race as a white baby born to a
white mother the most educated white
mother the most articulate white mother
tears the most affluent white mother
just by virtue of that baby drive his
first breath as an American now justice
monster say Reverend Jackson I know
that's not the case in America today but
I challenge anybody to say Tony that
that's not the goal worth fighting for
he said I challenge anybody to say
that's not what makes America the great
beacon of hope and justice for all the
world to Marvel so when we fight for the
gorge floors of the world but more
importantly when we fight for the
unknown
George floors of the world when we fight
for the Trayvon Martin's in the world
when we fight for the church crutches in
a world when we fight for the makeup
rounds of the world will we fight
without the Steelers of the world will
we pay for the Pearl and oka steals of
the world when we papered in jamya
clocks in a world when we've made for
the Eric Garner's in a world when we
fateful to send your blades in the world
will we make what amount accros in a
world when we pay for the Brianna
Taylor's of the world will we pay for
the Natasha bikinis of the world will
we've made for this step 9 Clark's in a
world when we make for the least of
these what we are really doing it's
helping America come live up to its
Creed well what we're really doing is
helping America be the great beacon of
hope and justice for all the world to
marvel but most importantly brothers and
sisters what we are doing is helping
America be America for all Americans
what we want tea is not to justice
systems in America one for black America
and one for white America what we
endeavor to achieve is equal justice for
the United States of America and George
Florida is the moment that gives us the
best opportunity I have seen in a long
time of reaching that high idea that
this country was founded on thank you so
much this is the plea for justice on
behalf of the family the children we
will get justice we are committed to it
now I would introduce you to a man who
really needs no introduction
who will eulogized George Floyd here's a
man who has fought for so many families
that too many hashtags to remember and
when he gets the call he always asks us
to call even when the cameras on around
even after the cameras are gone s Eric
Garner's family asked Stefan Clark's
family ask into these families the
chemists have long gone Tony but reven
el continues to answer the bell when our
people call he is a leader that you see
on TV commentating and about our
experiences but more importantly here's
a leader who has lived our experiences
and because he have lived those
experiences that's what makes him so
effective in commentating on MSNBC about
our experiences and he is going to talk
about the experience of the
terrible loss of somebody who should be
with us today and that is George flora
please give a great round of applause
for the reverend al sharpton thank you I
want us to not sit here and act like we
had a funeral on the schedule
George Floyd should not be among the
deceased he did not die of common health
conditions he died of a common American
criminal justice malfunction he died
because of there has not been the
corrective behavior that has taught this
country that if you commit a crime it
does not matter whether you wear blue
jeans or a blue uniform you must pay for
the crime you commit
so it is not a normal funeral it is not
a normal circumstance but it's too
common and we need to deal with it let
me ask those of you that in the
traditions of eulogies need a scriptural
reference go to Ecclesiastes 3rd chapter
first verse says to everything there is
a time and a purpose and season under
the heavens I'm going to leave the day I
saw somebody standing in front of a
church the other day wood had been
boarded up as a result of violence held
the Bible in his hand I've been
preaching since I was a little boy I
never seen anyone hold a Bible like that
but I'll leave that alone but she held
the Bible if he's watching us today I
would like him to open that Bible
and I'd like him to read it please yes
these three - every season there's a
time and a purpose and I think that it
is our job to let the world know when we
see what is going on in the streets of
this country and in Europe around the
world you need to know what time it is
first of all we cannot use Bibles as a
prop and for those that have agendas
that are not about justice this family
will not let you use George as a prophet
if you want to get your stubble off
don't use him let us stand for what is
right because when when I got the call
from attorney Crump
and usually when he calls me is not to
find out how I'm doing it is usually
because something happened that he wants
National Action Network and I to get
involved and he explained to me what was
happening with this case and I had
already heard about it in the media and
immediately I said well let me know what
you want me to do he said whatever you
need to do one of one of the things
Martin that I've always had to deal with
his critics would say all our shelter
wants is publicity well that's exactly
what I wanted cause nobody caused me to
keep a secret
people call me to blow up issues that
nobody else would deal with I'm gonna
blow up man and I don't apologize for
that cuz you get away too much with
hiding things
honey it's talked about y'all putting
clothes in the oven do have your coat
was dried well I think we're in the
third world but I grew up in third Ward
I grew in Brownsville and we had roaches
I know Kevin Hart and some of the rich
Hollywood folk he I don't know where
roaches are but we had roaches Ludacris
and one thing I found out about roaches
is that if you keep the light off if you
in the dark Roach will pull up to your
dinner table and have a five-course meal
so I learned one of the ways to deal
with roaches is if you cut the light off
I could run them roaches and track them
down and I've spent all my life chasing
roaches all over this country
as soon as I talked to the family and
got the details and heard that among
George's last words was I can't breathe
putting me on his neck I immediately
thought about air Gardiner I did the
eulogy at his funeral and I called his
mother and I said I know we're not going
out because of the coronavirus but this
is so much like Eric if we could arrange
some private way to go to Minneapolis
would you go
and she said red Mile I'm already
packing let me know Tyler Perry said
I'll give the families the plane
whatever y'all need because this is
wrong
Robert Smith said don't worry about the
funeral cause people across economic and
racial lands started calling and getting
in and we flew out here her in our last
Thursday and when I stood at that spot
reason it got to me is George
Freud story has been the story of black
folks because ever since 401 years ago
the reason we could never be who we
wanted and dream to be in is you kept
your knee on our neck
we were smarter than the underfunded
schools you put us in but you had your
knee on our neck we could run
corporations and not hustle in the
street but you had your knee on our neck
we had creative skills we could do
whatever anybody else could do but we
couldn't get your knee off my neck what
happened to Freud happens every day in
this country and education and health
services and in every area of American
life it's time for us to stand up in
George's name and say get your knee off
that's the problem no matter who you are
we thought maybe we had a complex ti
maybe it was just us but even blacks
that were broke through you kept your
knee on that neck Michael Jordan won all
these championships and you kept digging
for mess cuz you got to put a knee on
our neck weight housewives would run
home to see a black woman on TV named
Oprah Winfrey and you mess with her cuz
you just can't take your knee of our
neck man comes out of a single-parent
home educates himself and rises up and
becomes the president of the United
States
and you ask him for his bread
certificate
cuz you can't take your need of our neck
the reason why we're marching all over
the world is we were like George
we couldn't breathe not because there
was something wrong with our lungs but
but you wouldn't take your knee off our
neck we don't want no favors just get up
off of us and we can be and do whatever
we can be protests all over the world
some have looted and done other things
and none of us and this family condones
looting or violence but the thing I want
us to be real cognizant of is there is a
difference between those calling for
peace and those calling for quiet some
of y'all don't want peace you just want
quiet
you just want us to shut up and suffer
in the silence the overwhelming majority
of the people March 1 breaking windows
they were trying to break barriers they
weren't trying to steal nothing they
were trying to get back to justice you
stole from us those that broke the law
should pay for whatever Lord a broke but
so should the four policemen that caused
this funeral today we don't have a
problem denouncing violence mr. governor
we don't have a problem mr. mayor
denouncing Luton but it seems like some
in the criminal justice system have a
problem looking at a tape and knowing
there's probable cause and it takes a
long time for you to go and do what you
see that you need to do but um one that
has been krump said - and they're
working I've been involved a lot but
these fights we started around criminal
justice I did speeches and eulogies that
most of the funerals that we've had in
his face in the last couple of decades
and led to marches and he did what we
had to do I look at Martin the third we
went to jail together frightened these
fights like his daddy went to jail
before but I'm more hopeful today than
ever
why well let me go back room Jackson
always taught me stay on your texts come
back to my texts ecclesiastic there is a
time and a season and when I looked at
this time and saw marches where in some
cases young whites outnumbered the
blacks much I know that is a different
time and a different season when I
looked and saw people in Germany
marching for George flooring it's a
different time and a different season
when they went in front of the
parliament in London England
and said it's a different time and a
different season I come to tell you
America this is the time of building
with accountability in the criminal
justice system Stephen years ago I went
to March now I remember
young white lady looked me right in the
face
it said [ __ ] go home but when I was
here last Thursday and Miss Carr and I
was headed back to the airport I stopped
near the police station and I thought I
was talking to a reporter a young white
girl he didn't look no 10 11 years old
she tagged my suit jacket and I looked
around and I braced myself and she
looked at me and said no justice no
peace
there's a different time it's a
different season and my Bible carrying
God in front of that boarded-up Church
if I got him to open up the Bible I want
you to remember something you know I was
late last October to an appointment
because the time changed and I was still
my watch was on the wrong time
you know once a year time goes forward
and if you don't congresswoman oh my
move your watch you're gonna find
yourself hour late not because your
watch was wrong but you had your watch
on the wrong time
well I come to tell you that are sitting
in Washington talking about militarize
in the country thinking that you can
sell wolf tickets to people who's had
enough of abuse I come to tell you you
can get on the TV but you on the wrong
time time is out for not holding you
accountable time is out for you making
excuses time is out for you trying to
stall time is out for empty words and
empty promises time is out for you
filibustering and trying to stall the
arm of justice this is the time we won't
stop we will keep going until we change
the whole system of justice
our organizations have called us a day
of mourning in a ACP now sherbet League
Legal Defense Fund black woman's
roundtable lawyers committee all got
together said we gonna have a day of
mourning but then we gonna come out this
damn morning cuz that some of our
experts sherrilyn Ifill and others that
know the legal feel they've outlined a
legal process that we must enforce
everything from residency the dealing
with police background and not being
hidden doctor Governor Andrew Cuomo
today in New York he says we got to
change 58 where the backgrounds are stop
or policemen we need to know if they
stop you they find out everything you
ever did why don't we know when
policemen have a pattern we gotta go
back to consent decrees under the Obama
administration they had put certain
cities word patterns and practice under
consent decrees from Jamar Brian and oh
we use pass for the in Baltimore there
they put it under consent decree one of
the first thing that happened in the
next administration was they stopped the
consent decrees we have specific
policies that need to happen
therefore I'm glad mod in the third is
here today because on August 28th the
57th anniversary of the march on
Washington we're going back to
Washington Martin that's where your
father stood in the shadows of the
Lincoln Memorial and said I have a dream
where we're going back this August 28 to
restore and recommit that dream to stand
up because just like at one era we had
to fight slavery another era we had to
fight Jim Crow another era we dealt with
voting rights
this is the error to deal with policing
and criminal justice we need to go back
to Washington and stand up black white
Latino Arab in the shadows of Lincoln
and tell them this is the time to stop
this we Martin and I talked about this
I've had written Bryant to get the faith
leaders together talk brandy white God
about the labor leaders oh no we're
going to organize in the next couple of
months in every region not only for
March but for new process and it's gonna
be led by the Floyd family it's gonna be
led by the garner family and it's gonna
be led by those families that have
suffered this and knows the pain and
knows what it is to be neglected and
it's going to be getting us ready to
vote not just for who's gonna be in the
White House but the Statehouse and the
City Council's that allow these policing
measures to go on question we are going
to change the time let me say this to
the family who has shown such great
grace and real level and balanced
thinking and that's why I want them to
help lead this and I want think one of
the greatest thinkers of our time dr.
Michael Eric Dyson ivax come and speak
we need to break down cuz y'all don't
know what time it is y'all are operating
like it's yesterday and the reason y'all
late
catching up to what these protest means
is cuz you didn't turn your clock
forward talking about make America great
great for who and great win we gonna
make America great for everybody for the
first time
never was great for blacks Napa was
great for Latino what never great for
others wasn't great for women young
women had to march to get the right to
vote but lastly is the religious side I
was reading and kept thinking about how
I was a little embarrassed because when
I heard that George at this point of
suffering this brutal attack call for
his mama I said to turn the Crump I said
when I appreciate talking to his
brothers and him on the phone
but I won't talk to his mother he sent
his mother passed I said his mother
passed but he was calling for his mother
and I thought about it because I was
raised by a single mother and sometimes
the only thing between us and our
conditions was our mothers sometimes the
only thing that we had that would take
danger away was our mothers the only
ones that would make sure the food was
on the table was our mother I know why
George was calling for Mama but then as
I had got that all placed in my mind and
I realized why I was always calling and
my mother died eight years ago but I
still try to talk to her sometime just
dialing cell phone to hear the voice
mail or phone that I never cut off I
still want to reach out to mama but
talking to Quincy last night one of his
five children
Quincy said you know I was thinking
maybe he was calling his mother cuz at
the point that he was dying his mother
was stretching her hands out
saying come on George I welcome you
where the wicked will cease from
troubling when a weary will be at rest
there's a face where police don't clip
knees on your George there's a praise
that prosecutors don't drag their feet
maybe mama said come on George there's a
god
that still sits hot but he looks down
low and he'll make a way out of no way
this God it's still on the throne Greece
we can fight I don't care who's in the
White House there is another house that
said if we will fight he'll fight our
battles if we stand up he'll hold us up
so as we leave here today I say to this
family I know that years ago roll and
rhythm Jackson dolars keep hope alive
then I know that President Obama wrote a
book about hope but I want you to know
in my life there's times that I lost
hope things can happen like this that a
- your hope but there's something that
is sister to hope called faith faith is
the substance of things hoped for the
evidence of things unseen faith is when
you got a pile of bills and no money but
you say he will provide all of my needs
faith is when you got no medicine in the
cabinet and your stick in your body but
you say he's a doctor that never lost a
patient and he'll try tears from my eyes
faith is when your friends walk out when
your loved ones turned their back but
you say I don't believe he brought me
this far to leave me now we didn't come
this far by luck we didn't come this far
by some faith we come this far by faith
leaning on the Lord trusting in his holy
world he never he never he never failed
me yet from the outhouse to the white
house we come a long way God will God's
child God will God always hands he'll
make a way for children come on home
George get your rest George you change
the world judge we will keep marching
George we won't keep fighting George we
don't turn the cop George we won't
follow George time out time out time out
reacts gospel great Hezekiah Walker sing
a song for the family
after which Derek Johnson is in double
ACP asked me attorney crop we gonna
stand for 8 minutes and 46 seconds
though that was the time that George was
on the ground and we want you all over
the world to stand with us for eight
minutes and 46 seconds and make that
commitment for justice in the name of
George I want to thank the members of
the Congressional Black Caucus for being
with us won't you stand
I want to thank the Sun in air and coca
Vina dr. Martin Luther King the third
for being with us want to thank the
mayor and the governor and their Brides
for being with the family senator Amy
Klobuchar of the state of Minister of
Minnesota I want to thank our my mentor
and one who's fought this fight for more
than a half a century Reverend Jesse
Lewis Jackson is with us his folks man
for Rainbow PUSH Jonathan Luther Jackson
I want to thank I want to thank from the
entertainment world Kevin Hart he told
me don't mention he's here so don't clap
stand up Kevin we joke each other the
beloved stand up brother brother
Ludacris
Tyrese Gibson who's extraordinaire
activist in his own right Master P the
one and only the creative genius will
packet is with us today and a brother
that we've marched together and done a
lot of things he does not just put his
name on somebody's petition he puts his
body on the line brother Ti is in the
house I want this brothers one of the
greatest gospel singers alive
oh wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute I I didn't want to announce and
say I'm barrister let me tell you
something one of the most popular
outstanding artists that is also
committed I've read our interview she
think I'm old and don't read stuff but I
do and she's been committed and saying
the right things and she wanted to be
here today and I was so busy joking
would Kevin not even look at her let us
welcome our sister beloved sister
Tiffany Haddish is in the house
we're I'm Lauren I saw Loretta way to me
y'all know I got them all let us hear
selection from whether has a catwalk
compass everybody let's have some church
my god alright as we remain standing I
want to recognize cried Bella Court of
the American Indian Movement brother
bellacourt we honored that you came
thank you and let me say they recognize
someone yell out the state chair been
double ACP and many of black lives
matter
many of the grassroots organizations
that have been doing the protest on the
ground in many annapolis and around the
country movements are about everybody we
don't exclude anybody those young folks
some of them organic some organized on
their own some in ACP some urbanely
some Nash Action Network we need
everybody this is not a competition this
is a movement and we need to stop our
competing and start fighting the real
enemy
thank you for doing what y'all are doing
when I got here they were marching and
they kept my eye they didn't need nobody
to come or not something they organized
and we gonna stay organized and I really
thank them for their work we want to
pause for eight minutes and 46 seconds
I want you we because of the pandemic
I'm not going to actually to take hands
but I want you to stand next to someone
with the right distance amazing thing
about this movement people say they'd
never seen marches all over the country
well we had that but we never had it in
a pandemic the reason I know this is a
different time his people came out by
the hundreds of thousands at risk of
their own health to stand up people that
had been sheltered in broke out of
shelter first flight I took was to come
here in many weeks and maybe in God's
own way Martin in fact we were sheltered
means we couldn't watch sports couldn't
watch nothing we had to keep watching
that tape maybe because we had no
distractions that finally we're ready to
deal with this
so as we stand I would like us to stand
together and I think it only one woman
up here I want Oh Tiffany since I was
disrespectful would you come stand with
us over here Tiffany Haddish so you
won't be talking about me in your next
interview and I would like the mother of
Eric garner who's mother of the one who
originally died at police custody saying
I can't breathe to stand with me and Ben
Crump on stage
it's gwyn cough let us stand somebody
said Reverend eight minutes is a long
time that minute was long enough for the
police to understand what they were
doing meaning was long enough for one of
them three cops to stop what was going
on it means it was long enough for
whatever this off had in mind for him to
rethink as you go through these long
eight minutes think about what George
was going through laying there for those
eight minutes begging for his life heard
someone say narrating his own death we
can't let this go we can't keep living
like this
Sam Jackson is Sam still here we Steve
Jackson Steve Jackson is here Steve we
were recognized
I was recognizing everybody we got to
stop this here and we got to end this
time for about a new season let us stand
still you that believe in faith by your
heads or whichever way you worship
that's a long time if we've calculated
with the clock here that's how long he
was laying there there's no excuse they
had enough death now what will we do but
the time we have as we usher the family
out please let us take them out first
they have to prepare to go to North
Carolina and then back Euston where we
will do the final services they
appreciate you all for coming let us
everybody else be seated but the family
Reverend Bryant will you come quickly
give us a benediction just a benediction
and we're gonna take the family out
everyone else remain in your seats good
and gracious God merciful master walk
with us while we run this race speak to
us as we lift our voice use our hand not
become fists change our hearts so that
our rage will shift to rehabilitation
convict the country so it can finally
beat the land of the free and the home
of the brave we pray this prayer in the
name of the innocent black man by the
name of Jesus who is killed by a
government and still rose again and with
that power we march on until victory is
won
let's shoot a friend everyone except the
family please everyone please be seated
except the family let's let's let's
please everyone please remain in your
seat as we escort this family out thank
you so much thank you so much for your
cooperation thank you so much
wheezes at the family tree please be
pleased with the family it's it the
filter thank you for respecting this
family thank you so much god bless you
we want to say thank you to everyone who
has come today we want to say how much
we appreciate taking your time and we
are dismissed at this time and make your
way safely and respectfully as you
depart from the sanctuary have a
wonderful day
and this time we're gonna exit everyone
move out into the lobby I decided we're
gonna exit